DEMOCRATS CRANKING UP THE
OUTRAGE MACHINE AND GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOLLOWING THE
RELEASE OF COURT MEMOS ON PAUL
MANAFORT AND MICHAEL COHEN.
PARTY LEADERS PUSHING
IMPEACHMENT AND THE POSSIBILITY
OF PRISON TIME FOR THE PRESIDENT
OF PRISON TIME FOR THE PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
>> CERTAINLY THEY WOULD BE
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES.
EVEN THEY WERE COMMENDABLE FOR
THE -- COMMITTED BEFORE HE
BECAME PRESIDENT, THEY WERE
COMMITTED IN THE SERVICE OF
FRAUDULENTLY OBTAINING THE
OFFICE.
>> THERE’S A REAL PROSPECT THAT
ON THE DAY DONALD TRUMP LEAVES
OFFICE, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
MAY INDICT HIM.
HE MAY BE THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN
QUITE SOME TIME TO FACE THE REAL
PROSPECT OF JAIL TIME.
>> THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN ON
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS INNER
CIRCLE, INCLUDING HIS FAMILY.
>> THIS CRIMINAL MUST BE BROUGHT
UP BY THE CONGRESS OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> AND THE EVIDENCE BECOME SO
CLEAR THAT YOU VERY LIKELY HAVE
A CRIMINAL IN THE OVAL OFFICE,
WHAT IS THE CONGRESS LEFT TO DO
AT THAT POINT?
>> Jesse: OKAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIGHTING BACK
SAYING THAT THERE’S NO SMOKING
GUN, NO COLLUSION AND THAT THE
PAYMENT DETAILED IN THE COHEN
REPORT WAS A SIMPLE PRIVATE
TRANSACTION.
JUAN, I’M GOING TO USE AN
ANALOGY.
LET’S SAY HILLARY CLINTON --
BECAUSE GUTFELD IS NOT HERE.
LET’S SAY HILLARY CLINTON
DECIDED TO GET BOTOX IN DECEMBE
DECIDED TO GET BOTOX IN DECEMBE0
DECIDED TO GET BOTOX IN DECEMBE6
DECIDED TO GET BOTOX IN DECEMBE.
SHE PAID 10,000, 20,000,
WHATEVER IT COSTS.
SHE DECIDES SHE WANTS BOTOX.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT IT COSTS.
WHATEVER SHE PAYS.
SHE DOESN’T REPORTED TO THE FTC
AFTERWARDS AND SHE IS ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND THEN THE
REPUBLICANS FIND OUT.
HILLARY GOT BOTOX AND DID
REPORTING ON THE FEC FILING AND
NOW SHE NEEDS TO BE IMPEACHED.
WHAT WOULD BE THE DIFFERENCE?
>> Juan: THE DIFFERENCE.
SOMETIMES I THINK IT’S CHRISTMAS
SEASON, I’VE GOT TO BE NICER.
>> Jesse: PRIVATE TRANSACTION.
PRIVATE TRANSACTION.
BETWEEN HER AND THE BOTOX LADY.
>> Juan: JESSE, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION
POTENTIAL BY
INDIVIDUAL 1 ACCORDING TO HIS
FIXER WHO SAID INDIVIDUAL 1 TOLD
HIM TO MAKE THIS PAYMENT IN THE
CRITICAL MOMENT IN THE MIDST OF
A CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: BOTOX WOULD’VE BEEN
A CRITICAL MOMENT.
SHE’S ON TV.
>> Juan: I THINK THE BETTER
ANALOGY, WHEN SHE WAS SICK
PEOPLE ASKED HER IF SHE WAS SICK
AND SHE DIDN’T SAY AND THEN SHE
WAS STUMBLING TO THE CAR.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD TELL PEOPLE IF
YOU’RE SICK.
SIMILARLY I WOULD SAY WHEN
SOMEONE HIDES RELEVANT MATERIAL
FROM THE VOTERS, THE ARGUMENT IS
YOU ARE DECEIVING US.
>> Jesse: JUAN, IF YOU CAN
IMPEACH A POLITICIAN FOR BEING
DECEITFUL, WE WOULD NEVER
HAVEN’T PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: YOU DIDN’T SAY
IMPEACHED.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING ANYTHING.
REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE WE
WATCH THAT SOUND RIGHT THERE.
A LAWYER WHO DOES THIS FOR A
LIVING SAYS THIS IS BRAND
PROTECTION AND BRAND PROTECTION
IS NOT A CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATION.
IT’S PERFECTLY LEVO.
>> Dana: I GUESS THEY COULD
TRY THAT AND SEE WHAT WORKS.
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION IS
THIS.
THE LEAST INTERESTING PART ABOUT
THERE IS THE OVER
CRIMINALIZATION OF CAMPAIGN
FINANCE VIOLATIONS BUT WE DO
HAVE LAWS.
THEY ARE NOT CLEAR-CUT.
AFTER JOHN EDWARDS’ SITUATION,
HE WAS ACQUITTED BY ONLY BY A
JURY.
IT WENT ALL THE WAY.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAID WE HAVE
TO FULFILL OUR OBLIGATION AND
PROSECUTE TO THE FULLEST EXTENT
OF THE LAW.
BRAND PROTECTION COME I HAVEN’T
HEARD THAT ONE.
>> Jesse: YOU’RE WELCOME.
THE OTHER ISSUE, BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS, THEY HAVE A SLUSH FUND
WHERE THEY ARE PAYING OUT THESE
NONCONSENSUAL SETTLEMENTS OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS TO THE TUNE
OF SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS.
THEN PAYMENTS WERE MADE.
THIS IS A CONSENSUAL TRANSACTION
WHAT’S THE DIFFERENCE?
>> Brian: A COUPLE THINGS.
WHETHER YOU ARE ALL FOR
DONALD TRUMP ARE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP, THE WAY THE
INDICTMENT WAS WRITTEN ACCORDING
TO LEGAL EXPERTS WITH FLOWERY
LANGUAGE INSTEAD OF THE DRY
LEGALISTIC APPROACH, IT LOOKS AS
THOUGH THEY’RE GOING AFTER
TRUMP, NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
WHETHER YOU THINK THEY SHOULD OR
SHOULDN’T, LET’S PUT IT ASIDE.
THEY ARE GOING AFTER PROMPTED
TRY TO SAY HE DIRECTED MICHAEL
COHEN TO MAKE THE PAYMENTS.
TRUMP HAS TO THINK OF NOT
WHETHER IT’S RIGHT OR WRONG AND
COMPARE IT TO HILLARY CLINTON
ARE NOT AN OUTCOME IT DOESN’T
MATTER.
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK IS TRYING TO TAKE HIM
DOWN.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT DID HE
DECEIVE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ON?
DID ANYONE ACTUALLY THINK
DONALD TRUMP WAS THE SECOND
COMING OF SOME HIGH-LEVEL PULP?
NO, THEY KNEW HIS BACKGROUND.
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING ON.
IF YOU’RE IN THE BUSINESS WORLD
AND YOUR PARTNER DOESN’T LIKE
YOU AND YOUR GONNA RUN FOR
OFFICE, THAT PARTNER COMES OUT
AND SAYS THAT BRIAN KILMEADE, HE
ROBBED ME OF MONEY.
WHETHER HE DID OR NOT, YOU DON’T
WANT THAT PARTNER COMING FORWARD
WANT THAT PARTNER COMING FORWAR
FORWARD.
SO YOU WALK UP TO THE GEYER
WOMAN AND SAY WHAT’S GOING TO
TAKE TO PUT THIS AWAY?
I’VE GOT TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
YOU GET IT DONE.
MICHAEL COHEN BEING DIRECTED ARE
NOT BEING DIRECTED, THAT’S WHAT
THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK IS THE PROBLEM.
IF HE DOESN’T TAKE IT SERIOUS,
HE IS FOOLHARDY.
HE HAS TO GET ON THE OFFENSIVE
HERE, ADDRESS IT DIRECTLY, GO
AFTER IT.
OPINIONS SHOULD NOT MATTER.
DON’T CHEERLEAD OR BOO.
THIS IS THE REALITY.
>> Jesse: NOW IT’S JUST THE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
>> Morgan: I AM STILL TRYING
TO WRAP MY HEAD AROUND THE BOTOX
ANALOGY.
>> Jesse: IT’S AIRTIGHT.
>> Brian: INSURANCE SHOULD BE
COVERING THAT.
>> Jesse: WEIGHT, INSURANCE
COVERS THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Morgan: I DON’T THINK
IMPEACHMENT OVER THESE ISSUES
WORK FOR --
IT BACKFIRED ON THE REPUBLICANS
I THINK WOULD BACKFIRE ON THE
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU START TO HAVE IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS IN THE HOUSE AND LATER
IN THE SENATE, THINK ABOUT WHO’S
GOING TO BE THOSE HEARINGS
TESTIFYING.
IT’S GOING TO BE STORMY DANIELS,
AVENATTI IS GOING TO BE THERE.
THINK ABOUT THE CHAOS THAT
AVENATTI ENSUED DURING THE
KAVANAUGH HEARINGS.
SOME PEOPLE THINK IT’S A THREE
RING CIRCUITS
THREE-RING CIRCUS.
SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT DURING
THE KAVANAUGH HEARINGS, THE
WHOLE THING HE WAS DOING THERE
SORT OF GAVE KAVANAUGH A WIN.
IF YOU TAKE A STEP BACK AND
THINK WITH THE IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS COULD LOOK LIKE WITH
THIS CAST OF CHARACTERS, IT
WOULD BE TERRIBLE FOR DEMOCRATS
GOING INTO 2020.
IF THAT’S WHAT THEY WANT TO DO,
THEY WANT TO BRING AVENATTI
BEFORE CONGRESS AND STORMY
DANIELS.
>> Brian: THEY ARE TRYING TO
MAKE HIM UNELECTABLE.
>> Jesse: IS THIS ABOUT SEX
AGAIN?
ARE WE BACK IN THE ’90s?
IS IT ALL JUST OUTRAGE ABOUT SEX
IS IT ALL JUST OUTRAGE ABOUT SE
SEX?
A CAMPAIGN FINANCE REPORTING
ERROR IS IMPEACHABLE?
>> Juan: THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE REALLY DEALING WITH
HYPOCRISY?
THEY WOULD AGREE --
IT’S ABOUT LYING.
THE PRESIDENT, EVEN AFTER HE WAS
ELECTED TO OFFICE, SAID HE
DIDN’T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
A PAYMENT TO ANY OF THESE WOMEN.
>> Jesse: THAT WE ARE BACK TO
LYING ABOUT SEX?
>> Juan: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I’M A DEMOCRAT IN 2018 AND I AM
SAYING, AS BRIAN SAID, IT’S A
SERIOUS CHARGE BY THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT, THE FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS IN NEW YORK, AGAINST
INDIVIDUAL NUMBER 1, UNNAMED BUT
WIDELY ASSUMED --
>> Jesse: I DON’T THINK THEY
EVER PROSECUTED CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATIONS AS FELONIES.
>> Dana: EIGHT WAS PROSECUTED IN
>> Dana: EIGHT WAS PROSECUTED IT
>> Dana: EIGHT WAS PROSECUTED IE
JOHN EDWARDS CASE.
THE QUESTION WAS, DID HE DIRECT
THE CAMPAIGN DONOR TO DO IT FOR
HIM?
IT DIDN’T HAPPEN.
HE WAS ACQUITTED BY A JURY BUT
ALSO HE WASN’T PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OR EVEN
VICE PRESIDENT.
IT’S MURKY.
I THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE A BIG
COMMUNICATIONS PROBLEM ON THEIR
HANDS.
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE AUDIENCES TO
TALK TO ALL AT ONCE.
THEY HAVE A RESTLESS BASE WHO
WANT TO DO NOTHING BUT GO AFTER
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE NEW MEMBERS WHO SAY I
JUST THOUGHT ARE REALLY TOUGH
CAMPAIGN.
I WANT TO DO STUFF.
I WANT TO WORK ON HEALTH CARE.
I CAN TELL YOU IF THEY GO DOWN
THIS ROAD OF JUST DOING
IMPEACHMENT, IT BASICALLY TAKES
UP ALL THE OXYGEN.
THERE’S NO TIME TO DO ANYTHING
ELSE.
SO THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
PEOPLE GET DEMORALIZED.
PEOPLE WANT TO LEAVE.
I WAS LOOKING FOR A WAY TO GO TO
I ENDED UP LEAVING THE CONGRESS,
LEAVE THE CONGRESS.
BASICALLY THEY SPENT A YEAR AND
HALF GOING AFTER BILL CLINTON
AND IT WAS KIND OF BORING AS A
STAFFER.
IT WASN’T GOING ANYWHERE.
POLITICALLY THEY HAVE A HUGE
PROBLEM ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
>> Brian: ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
IF YOU’RE WORRIED ABOUT THEM
OVERSTEPPING, YOU SAW THIS
WEEKEND EXTREME LANGUAGE.
IT WAS BROUGHT UP BY ANDREW
McCARTHY WHO WENT TO COLLEGE
FOR A LAW DEGREE, VERY SMART
GUY.
HE SAYS IN 2008, BARACK OBAMA
WAS GUILTY OF VIOLATIONS TO THE
TUNE OF $2 MILLION.
HE PAID A $275,000 FINE.
THIS WHOLE THING WAS COHEN WAS
$280,000.
IT SHOULD JUST BE A FINE.
>> Juan: IT’S APPLES AND
ORANGES BUT I WILL LEAVE IT
ALONE.
WE NEED TO GO TO A BREAK.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH BARACK OBAMA,
IT WAS A MATTER OF OVERPAYMENT,
UNDERPAYMENT.
IT WASN’T A MATTER OF GUESS
WHAT, I’M GOING TO TAKE MONEY
AND USE IT TO ADVANCE MY
CAMPAIGN WITHOUT CLOSING.
HE HID THE FACT THAT HE WAS
PAYING MONEY TO THESE WOMEN.